j'ai reçu aujourd'hui le Xiaomi 13 pro
qui est là je suis en train de filmer
avec donc je vous avais fait une vidéo
pour vous parler du Xiaomi 13 Pro
version chinoise là on n'est pas sur la
version chinoise là on est sur la
version française on va donc regarder ce
que vaut ce chien mitress Pro version
française à quelques petites différences
bien évidemment la configuration
matériel reste exactement la même on va
quand même regarder néanmoins quels sont
les différences et est-ce qu'elles sont
intéressantes voilà c'est cool et puis
on va regarder la photo on va regarder
la vidéo la vidéo on la voit là je suis
en train de filmer en 4K 60 images on va
regarder ce qu'on peut faire bref ça
c'est intéressant c'est un programme qui
est très cool aujourd'hui on part en
immersion à la découverte de ce Xiaomi
13 pro est-ce que vous êtes prêt vous
êtes prêts allez on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant
le Xiaomi 13 Pro est arrivé dans cette
boîte c'est la version française l'autre
jour je vous ai montré la version
chinoise celle-ci que j'ai été moi
acheté directement en Chine et la
version française qui est arrivé là
alors il existe différentes couleurs à
bien évidemment c'est pas la couleur de
la Chine à couleur de la France non mais
je vais dans cette couleur là alors je
vais pas vous refaire le tour complet du
produit l'aspect esthétique l'écran
légèrement incurvé qui est très sympa
tous les côtés bref pas de prise directe
ça je vous l'ai déjà fait je voulais
déjà montré on va regarder différentes
choses on va commencer regardez toute la
partie photo vidéo sur une balader j'ai
fait plein de choses avec donc ça on va
le regarder on regardera juste après la
question de la performance parce que
vous avez le nouveau temps dragon
8 de l'autonomie puis tous les petits
plus en plus qui sont intéressants mais
déjà on va commencer par regarder cette
partie photo un triptyque 50 mégapixels
grand angle ultra grand-angle tel
objectif on oublie la caméra de selfie
qu'on trouve à l'avant qui est une 32
mégapixels alors vous avez différents
modes colorimétrie ici on a deux modes
Leica vibrant le Leica authentique
première chose qu'on va faire c'est
faire des photos en les cas authentique
c'est la base c'est authentique je vous
emmène à Clermont place de jeux donc on
va regarder ce qu'on peut venir shooter
ici déjà quelques photos grand angle
ultra grand-angle tel objectif tout en
sachant qu'ici on est sur un triptyque
50 mégapixels sauf la selfie qui est en
32 méga pixels le gros point positif de
ce smartphone c'est qu'il hérite du
capteur du Xiaomi 12S qu'on avait
l'année dernière qui était pas sorti en
France sorti uniquement en Chine un gros
capteur de 1 pouce sauf que à l'époque
et bien le stade dragon 8 gène 1 qu'il y
avait sur le 12 s'était pas en capacité
tout seul devenir avoir un capteur de 1
pouce il lui fallait un coprocesseur
d'images ici le stade dragon 8 gène 2 va
tout faire maison tout seul directement
et le résultat est bon si vous regardez
alors là on est sur le Leica authentique
c'est-à-dire que c'est la colorimétrie
signature de Leica vibreur sera un peu
plus saturé un peu plus exposé ça c'est
colorimétrie purement Leica et ça
fonctionne si vous regardez c'est beau
c'est joli alors bon je vous laisse
apprécier par vous même le panorama de
la place de jeux de Clermont-Ferrand
mais au-delà du côté sympa d'avoir les
galeries de Jaude ici et bien tout est
respecté on voit du détail alors je vous
ai vraiment fait les photos en mode
automatique comme on prend smartphone on
l'achète on fait les photos je suis pas
venu chercher des réglages plus
professionnel je suis pas venu shooter
en haut on pourra aller faire plus de
choses dans l'image et la retoucher
c'est pas le but parce que le but pour
moi c'est de montrer l'usage de tout un
chacun est-ce que vous avez ici entre le
grand-angle et l'ultra grand-angle est
très cohérence à marche bien oui j'ai un
peu haute plage un peu désaxé lorsque
j'ai fait les photos ensuite vous avez
un truc qui est intéressant c'est à dire
que vous venez zoomer vous passez en X 2
mais en fait sur le X 2 vous restez sur
votre capteur de 50 mégapixels votre
capteur grand angle c'est un X 2
numérique et vous arrivez ensuite sur
l'optique à partir du X 3,2 c'est un peu
différent en fait là je suis en faux 3,2
et oui ça c'est le X 2 on va quand même
beaucoup plus loin que X 3,2 je sais pas
c'est l'impression que c'est 1 x 4 par
des fois un fois 5 mais bon ça s'appelle
le X 3,2 mais pour autant ça marche donc
vous avez bien le détail on a un très
bon piqué ici ça fonctionne bien la
luminosité est bonne la question de la
lumière est bonne la gestion de la
couleur marche bien tout va bien après
je suis venu chercher un peu plus loin
je suis allé en X 10 oh ça commence à se
compliquer fatalement parce qu'on arrive
en X 10 ensuite je suis allé en x 30 x
70 je vous le dis vous allez le voir on
va éviter on reprend la même chose ici
sur votre grand angle xant ça marche
bien gestion de haute lumière ça
fonctionne bien on a bien tous les
détails à droite ici à gauche on a bien
le glaive de Vercingétorix salut à toi
alors ça j'ai Torix ultra grand-angle va
bien une petite différence est
légèrement plus bleutée on le voit au
niveau du ciel vous voyez l'ultra
grand-angle est légèrement ici plus
bleuté on vient en X 2 c'est le X 2
numérique x 3,2 on est sur l'optique
c'est une fois de plus très bien
maîtrisé très beau ça sort très très
bien ensuite je viens en X 10 alors déjà
vous voyez on voit qu'il y a beaucoup
plus de bruit sur l'image c'est beaucoup
moins bien la qualité des grades quand
même en X 10 je vais ensuite chercher du
X 30 ça pique un peu et le X 70 on peut
mettre très clairement on y va pas je
vous le recommande pas la même chose ici
il y a un peu de brume un peu de
brouillard on n'est pas sur les plus
belles journées mais voisin on passe sur
l'ultra grand temps que ça fait le taf
le piqué sera un peu moins bon ben ultra
grand temps que ça me paraît normal le X
2 numérique fait le taf le X 3.2 ici en
optique fait le taf on se rapproche un
peu en X 10 vous voyez qu'on perd quand
même tout de suite l'algo vient
récupérer un peu des choses mais on perd
la qualité est pas super et si je veux
regarder par rapport à mettre en face un
Galaxy S23 ultra il y a une différence
il y a aussi une différence de prix mais
il y a quand même une vraie différence x
30 x 70 vous voyez ils sont pas
exploitables pas du tout fait exactement
la même position alors vous voyez il y a
aussi un truc qui est différent et on le
regardera probablement c'est entre ce
qu'on a au niveau algorithmique entre le
S23 ultra et le Xiaomi 13 pro pour voir
qu'on a exactement les mêmes processeurs
on n'a pas le même traitement d'image
après bon voilà chacun pourra venir y
trouver son bonheur ou pas on sera un
comparatif hein je pense très bientôt
pour venir regarder avec même processeur
ce qu'ils arrivent à sortir entre d'un
côté Samsung et d'un côté Xiaomi avec
son boulot qui est fait avec les cas ici
ça va être un truc qui est vraiment
intéressant donc grand angle ultra
grand-angle x 2 x 3,2 qui est beaucoup
plus bleu bon ça c'est vraiment tout de
suite hyper hyper flagrant vous voyez au
niveau vraiment au niveau du ciel le X
10 on commence à deviner les crottes de
pigeon sur la tête c'est pas terrible on
va jusqu'au x 30 à peu près x 70 voilà
c'est à peu près la même chose donc on a
vraiment le même point de détail
lorsqu'on vient regarder c'est plutôt
bien alors une fois de plus j'aurais
aimé avoir un peu plus de soleil pour
vous montrer plus de choses mais on est
en hiver c'est comme ça mais on
rajoutera de choses après une petite
différence à si vous regardez réellement
vous voyez entre le X1 c'est très blanc
c'est blanc ici au niveau de la
colorimétrie de la façade là on est
toujours sur le X 1 en numérique et dès
qu'on passe en photo optique la façade
devient un peu plus jaune vous voyez ici
là une petite différence de colo c'est
pas grand chose mais quand même une
différence voilà tout ce que je voulais
vous montrer un peu sur le Leica
authentique
voilà pour des images tournées en les
cas authentique maintenant je vais vous
faire quelques images en les Caval Brent
pour vous puissiez voir la différence
alors si vous avez regardé ma première
vidéo je teste sur le Xiaomi 13 pro que
j'avais fait avec la version chinoise et
bien vous avez vu que Skype le Leica
vibreur forcément ça va être légèrement
plus saturé c'est une colorimétrie Leica
vous savez peut-être mais là il
partenariat avec les cas avant c'était
Huawei qu'il a maintenant Huawei la plus
c'est Xiaomi qui là et on va regarder
enfin je vous montre c'est pas se faire
couper en deux est-ce que vous préférez
en terme de mode après il y a un truc à
savoir c'est tout ce que vous allez
venir filmer ici vous avez pas de mode
colorimétrique ça va être uniquement un
seul mode colorimétrie vous avez pas le
choix entre les Caval bright like a
authentique en vidéo non bien seulement
c'est celui-là et pas plus pas moi la
différence que vous allez avoir ici sur
les cabane ça va être des photos qui
vont être un peu plus saturées un peu
plus flatteuse pas énormément c'est pas
le truc non plus mais un peu plus
alors effectivement une fois de plus la
météo n'est pas un son maximale pour
nous apporter beaucoup de lumière mais
on va quand même voir que le résultat
est là on a effectivement beaucoup de
détails et ça j'aime beaucoup avec ce
smartphone et je trouve très joli là
dessus au niveau du piqué il est très
très bon et on a vraiment du détail du
dragon donc ce sera un peu moins précis
mais c'est un ultra grand-angle une fois
de plus et à peu près la même chose on
vient se rapprocher et zoomer vous voyez
hop là c'est pareil le fois en le fois
06 ultra grand-angle on vient en X 2
numérique en X 3 points 2 optique x 10
ça lui a Valérie ensuite on est en X 30
et en X 70 vous voyez c'est la même
chose que je vais vous montrer tout à
l'heure sauf qu'effectivement on est
venu mettre l'autre fit le les
cavaillement qui apportera un peu plus
saturation au niveau des couleurs un peu
plus des classes c'est un peu l'idée ici
mais sinon on est de façon sur les mêmes
capteurs on aura de toute façon le même
rendu la même qualité voilà bon après il
faut bien reconnaître aujourd'hui que
très honnêtement les conditions météo
sont pas du tout optimales donc je sais
pas si vous allez bien vous rendre
compte de la différence entre le les cas
les cas vibrant le Leica authentique je
vous invite à aller voir ma vidéo où
j'ai filmé directement avec le
smartphone version chinoise que j'ai
acheté directement les sur que j'ai
acheté en Chine où j'ai des photos ou un
peu plus de soleil vous verrez davantage
le côté les capable par rapport au Leica
authentique mais je pense que déjà là
comme ça vous le voyez ça devrait aller
bon alors là on s'est regardé le lait
qui brunch les cas authentique en tant
que travaux de selfie à dire regardez
alors moi cette caméra de selfie il y a
des choses qui me semble pas mauvaises
il y a des fois ce traitement de peau
qu'on trouve vraiment qui est propre au
constructeur chinois et pas mal chez
Xiaomi c'est que ça vient un peu trop
lissé donc il y a un côté un peu sympa
là c'est un truc un peu plus jeune
néanmoins j'ai quand même un peu de
grains de peau ça vient pas trop trop au
lycée j'ai l'impression que ça lisse et
plus sur la version chinoise peut-être
une petite différence ici après des fois
il a du mal certains contre-jour vous
voyez là par exemple les si tout est
cramé les branches d'arbres il a du mal
c'est cramer c'est difficile il est
vraiment à faire le focus sur mon visage
mais le reste autour on a l'impression
qu'il ne travaille pas indépendamment
donc c'est là-dessus je vais trouver un
peu moins efficace j'ai bien des ombres
ok mais je trouve que la définition est
pas ouf là il a eu du mal à ce que je
fais c'est quand je mets je me mets un
contre-jour comme ça c'est vraiment pour
voir s'il arrive à me faire ressortir
mon visage elle a annoncé tout sombre
j'en ai fait d'autres là je suis bien
exposé avec la lumière vient d'en face
ça va ça fonctionne on a du détail c'est
pas mal mais il y a un petit traitement
au niveau de la peau que
[Applaudissements]
les choses comme les autres c'est-à-dire
que eux sur leur smartphone lorsque vous
venez shooter macro et lorsque vous
passez en mode super macro vous venez
dans vos paramètres vous venez ici et
vous passez en Super Macro la Super
Macro elle vit à passer sur le
téléobjectif elle est pas sur l'ultra
grand-angle si je mets en face un Galaxy
S23 ultra ici je suis en macro sur
l'ultra grand-angle et en fait le truc
qui est vraiment différent ici c'est que
je pourrais pas venir d'aussi près je
vous montre je prends par exemple mon
S23 ultra on va essayer de bien le
mettre dans le cadre que vous voyez bien
la pierre donc là j'ai bien la pierre je
me rapproche de ma pierre de manière à
voir c'est de la poser à peu près plate
de manière à avoir une photo qui soit
exploitable voilà donc là je suis nette
vous voyez je peux venir prendre une
photo que je peux me rapprocher
davantage non je peux dire à me
rapprocher très légèrement comme ça vous
voyez là je suis nette après si je veux
je peux venir zoomer un peu dans mon
image alors pas trop pas en X 3 parce
qu'on voit changer d'optique mais
jusqu'au x 2 hop là je reviens je peux
le faire un peu ça me fait un petit zoom
numérique donc je peux venir jusqu'à un
œuf et là je peux venir zoomer donc là
vous voyez je suis dans avec mon S23
ultra lui il bosse vraiment différemment
donc là je suis en mode super macro vous
voyez je me suis mis loin c'est-à-dire
que si je me rapprocher comme moi
j'étais là tout à l'heure avec le S23
comme je suis pas sur l'ultra grand
temps je peux pas me rapprocher ce qui
veut dire que je m'en fous pas à me
rapprocher mais que la seule distance de
netteté c'est cette distance là vous
voyez là je suis pas net là je suis
nette donc en fait là je suis en Super
Macro et ensuite je peux venir après
bricoler un peu et venir zoomer dans
l'image mais c'est un espèce de
bricolage en X 2 je trouve que pour le
garder en plus bien stabilisé surtout
moi avec un tremblement essentiel ben
c'est pas drôle donc voyez là j'ai un
truc mais en fait ma distance de netteté
elle est pas hyper évidente c'est pas
facile facile à trouver donc venir
ajouter de la macro avec le Xiaomi 13
pro et plus difficile et moins
intéressant que venir shooter de la
macro avec le Galaxy S23 ultra et si
vous regardez le résultat il est pour
moi sans appel et c'est là dessus ou je
vais trouver que Xiaomi est pas très
très bon sur cette question de la macro
je pense pas qu'il ait pris de la
meilleure des façons et c'est une fois
de plus un peu dommage regardez la macro
prise avec le Xiaomi 13 pro ok bon la
macro si on veut voilà c'est pas voilà
il a la micro prise avec le Galaxy S23
ultra on va aller plus loin on fera un
peu plus de choses et je trouve que
c'est beaucoup plus joli c'est plus
saturé c'est meilleur qualité donc je
vais trouver que sur la macro c'est pas
ouf et du coup le rendu que vous avez
dans la nature et parlez pas d'aller
assez loin je trouve que c'est un peu
frustrant alors pour autant le capteur
est bonne qualité on sort des choses qui
sont sympas mais par rapport à ce qu'on
peut voir sur d'autres smartphones en
allant chercher plus loin au niveau de
la macro et bien là on a une barrière
physique du fait de yoshooter avec un
téléobjectif en fait vous prenez votre
téléobjectif et vous venez zoomer et là
vous aurez toute pas mal c'est en fait
un espèce de zoom numérique avec le
téléobjectif mais c'est pas réellement
de la macro tel qu'on peut l'entendre
sur un smartphone un peu classique voilà
si on veut aller sur la Super Macro
alors on peut pas dire que c'est mauvais
mais si on veut venir chercher ici à
l'intérieur on ne peut pas après c'est
un choix à voir hein on peut aussi se
dire ouais je préfère que ça fonctionne
comme ça je préfère d'avoir ce rendu là
il me plaît davantage mais si je veux
venir chercher les petits poils à
l'intérieur et bien je n'aurai pas les
petits poils à l'intérieur de ma plante
et maintenant je vous montre en les
cabane voici sur le lait Caval brut au
niveau de la macro forcément ça sera un
peu plus coloré un peu plus saturé alors
c'est pas non plus la grande folie mais
c'est un peu plus saturé c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal mais pour moi ce n'est pas
de la macro c'est à dire que c'est des
photos dans lesquelles on est venu
zoomer dedans mais ce n'est pas de la
macro mais c'est joli mais ce n'est pas
de la macro et également la photo de
nuit la photo de nuit mais également la
vidéo de nuit alors la vidéo de nuit on
peut venir filmer soit en 1080p soit en
4K dans les deux cas 24 images par
seconde ici il y a pas de 60 images par
seconde alors pour autant vous pouvez
passer en mode normal en 4K à 60 images
par seconde quand je vous montre la
différence donc ça c'est la 4K normal 60
images par seconde normal vidéo en
dehors du mode nuit spéciale en vidéo
mais ici chez omi nous a créé un mode
nuit spécial vidéo donc il est
probablement probablement plus
intéressant donc on reçoit sur ce mode
nuit 4K 24 images par seconde et on va
aller faire des photos de nuit puis bien
évidemment je compte sur vous pour me
dire ce que vous en pensez en bas dans
les commentaires c'est un petit peu là
où on attendait au détour du chemin ce
Xiaomi 13 pro c'est sur la photo de nuit
pourquoi parce que vous avez un très
plus gros capteur de 1 pouce qui va
capter plus de lumière plus toute la
capacité de calcul du snood dragon 8
gène 2 qui est très cool et qu'on a
vraiment envie de voir et le résultat
est là regardez-moi sur la photo de nuit
c'est super bien moi je voyais pas ça je
vous assure je voyais pas ça le ciel est
super bien dégagé on va du blanc on voit
bien les nuages on a bien la matière
pour autant les lumières il y a un peu
de dance flair c'est à dire que vous
voyez un petit peu des petits artefacts
lumineux mais qui fonctionne et qui
posent pas de problème on a bien le
détail on voit bien l'herbe on voit bien
la poubelle on va bien tout tout est
bien vu et préserver et ça c'est
vachement bien même la lumière là est
belle la tout est beau tout est beau
donc ça c'est vrai que ça m'est
vachement en valeur alors on peut venir
shooter à l'ultra grand angle je vous le
recommande pas on peut venir shooter
avec le zoom x 3,2 le zoom optique on
peut le faire faut-il le faire je sais
pas convaincu mais le 1 pouce il est
magnifique regardez le 1 pouce une fois
de plus mise à part la lumière qui est
là le ciel est top tout est top les
éclairages je trouve vraiment vraiment
bien un peu moins bien sur le côté un
peu moins précis sur le côté mais au
centre de l'image c'est très très beau
là c'est pareil regardez j'ai la lumière
mais j'ai la matière c'est très beau
j'ai la matière là sur les voitures je
trouve ça vraiment vraiment très très
jolie là c'est pareil qui est en de 1
pouce la lumière est bien là ici là
c'est maîtrisé je vois ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur j'ai à l'intérieur de la
banque bref c'est toi bon l'ultra grand
temps que je passe le X 2 et demi je
passe un peu de matière là également il
y a aussi un côté un peu flou naturel
qu'on va retrouver derrière au niveau du
véhicule je trouve très très beau mais
ça je trouve que c'est vraiment bien
fait pareil le ciel ici qui est vraiment
bien maîtrisé au niveau de la lumière ça
fonctionne j'ai bien tout le devant de
l'Église qui est extrêmement bien
valorisé très très très joli boulot
alors je suis venu chercher un peu le
bazar voir que ça donnait parce que je
poussais vraiment sur les lampes mais il
s'en sort quand même pas trop mal vu la
difficulté de la scène là c'est pareil
je trouve ça super joli on voit bien
l'intérieur de la boutique on voit bien
là ça qui est dans l'ombre on le voit
bien c'est dans l'ombre ça marche dans
l'ombre ça marche pour autant on va bien
l'intérieur bref tout est très bien
égalisé c'est beau il y a de la matière
c'est juste c'est beau voilà je peux pas
dire autre chose ça très beau et très
bien fait une fois de plus une rue aussi
super bien éclairer une reconversante
avec la lumière qui est bien qui ressort
bien on a bien l'éclairage des boutiques
une belle ambiance en fait qui ressort
ici même sur un arbre de nuit retrouve
différentes couleurs alors il faut
savoir qu'ici vous avez également le
Leica vibrant le Leica authentique je
voulais laisser sur vibreur voilà je
pouvais pas non plus la nuit je pense
que c'est pas on va récupérer plus de
trucs mais si vous voulez on également
venir choisir son modifier alors voyez
la photo de nuit avec le capteur de 1
pouce pour moi c'est un oui c'est un
très gros oui la vidéo de nuit en mode
nuit est un peu mieux que la vidéo en
mode standard mais c'est pas
extraordinaire c'est pas non plus
anormal c'est pas fait même si c'est un
capteur de 1 pouce pour me dire filmer
la nuit mais par contre le rendu en
photo de nuit ça j'aime beaucoup au
niveau de la vidéo on a différents modes
différents choix là je suis en 4K à 60
images par seconde on peut aussi se
faire de la 4K en 30 images de la 4K en
24 images mais on peut également faire
de la 8k en 24 images ici uniquement 24
images par seconde et si on peut pas se
faire de 8k en 30 images par seconde
alors c'est un truc qu'on peut faire
chez Samsung vous voyez pour voir qu'on
a le même processeur c'est le Sun dragon
8 GN2 on peut venir faire de la 8k en 30
images par seconde ici on est limité à
24 images par seconde très honnêtement
pour moi vous allez pas venir filmer en
8k 30 images par seconde 24 images par
seconde bon je pense que vous allez
rester en 4K maximum 60 images par
seconde d'autant plus que hop là où
j'aurai la meilleure stabilisation ça va
effectivement être en 4K à 60 images par
seconde mais je peux avoir aussi une
super stabilisation et une stabilisation
pro mais par contre là je vais descendre
uniquement en 1080p et le 1080p c'est un
peu moins ça en termes de stade ça va
être moins cool et 1080p ça va être
moins bien que de résolution d'image
donc c'est pas vraiment ce que je vous
recommander ici regardez là je suis en
1080p la chance super stabilisation pro
alors c'est là où j'ai avec le mieux
stabilisé mais je suis uniquement en
1080p donc forcément c'est pas grave
résolution et c'est pas ce que je vais
venir vous recommander ici non après sur
la caméra de selfie le seul truc qui
relou ce sera vraiment dommage c'est que
je suis uniquement 1080p à 36 matchs par
seconde j'ai pas de possibilité d'avoir
une 4x4 sur cette caméra de selfie et
sur un smartphone qui veut extrêmement
premium je trouve ça quand même
relativement dommage donc ça vous voyez
c'est un truc où je veux dire c'est un
peu moyen ça serait bien de monter la
résolution sur la caméra de selfie
surtout qu'on fait vachement de gens
utilisent cette caméra de selfie pour
faire du vlog pour les créateurs sur Tik
Tok et compagnie donc ça c'est un peu
dommage quand même et après il existe
d'autres modes pour venir filmer
notamment le mode Dual vidéo comme là où
je vais avoir la caméra de selfie la
caméra arrière bon on peut venir
l'utiliser personnellement je trouve que
ça ça pas grand chose bah ça peut vous
intéresser
est-ce que c'est un truc qui peut vous
intéresser de venir filmer comme ça ou
pas du tout bon voilà c'est des petits
mods ils ont également le un blog qui
peut aussi être intéressant je suis pas
convaincu globalement par cette paysage
là mais il y a des gens qui à qui ça
pourra plaire on va essayer de se faire
une fois de plus couper en deux par les
bagnoles voilà donc il y a plein de
petits modes qui viennent exister mais
bon pour moi le mieux c'est quand même
de venir filmer en 4K à 60 images par
seconde c'est là où on aura la meilleure
qualité et c'est normal ce que je vous
recommande c'est de venir filmer
directement comme ça vous passez en
ultra grand-angle en 4K 6 images par
seconde ça sera tout aussi bien le taf
ça ira très très bien et voilà c'est ce
que j'ai à vous recommandé alors moi
j'ai une perche à selfie tout de suite
qui me permet effectivement de venir
l'éloigner avec un micro comme ça c'est
cool vous l'aurez pas vous
nécessairement mais si vous voulez en
tout cas venir à maximiser l'expérience
4K à 60 images par seconde sur l'ultra
grand-angle ils ont peut-être pas la
meilleure stabilisation et globalement
ça sera franchement le tas si vous avez
pas vu ma vidéo sur mon skate là je vous
invite à venir le voir ça envoie du bois
c'est quand même très très cool il faut
quand même faire extrêmement attention
sur la route j'ai beau avoir mon casque
je suis en train de me filmer en même
temps que je vous parle avec une face à
cette fille je suis pas sur la meilleure
idée pas sûr alors sur la partie vidéo
soyons clairs c'est bien c'est très bien
sur le capteur sur les capteurs arrière
hop là il est juste là que vous allez
avoir sur le grand angle et l'ultra
grand temps que ça fera le taf en 4K le
sentiment par seconde dès que vous
descendez en 1080p la qualité est
vraiment beaucoup moins bonne et c'est
pas terrible au-delà du fait de perdre
en résolution c'est plus terne et moins
joli on le voit sur la couleur globale
de l'image c'est pas ouf et la caméra de
selfie pour moi c'est un gros point
négatif également parce que ça va pas du
tout c'est pas joli c'est pas du tout
adapté et pour moi là-dessus Xiaomi et
pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on peut
retrouver sur d'autres smartphones
notamment je vous le prends une fois de
plus où je l'ai mis le S23 ultra c'est
un peu dommage alors soyons clairs ce
smartphone je l'aime bien je trouve
plutôt pas mal après il a un petit peu
lourd et assez épais donc si vous prenez
ce smartphone c'est que vous aimez les
smartphones un peu grand un peu épais
c'est pas le plus petit du marché ça
c'est clair il fait c'est 229 g
clairement à côté ça je trouve bien
réussi Corning Horia glace victus à
l'avant à l'arrière il est certifié IP68
résistant à la poussière qui se
déverrouille très rapidement on aura
plus de ça un très joli écran ça c'est
vachement bien c'est un des gros point
fort aussi de ce smartphone c'est que
vous avez une très belle dalle incurvée
sur le côté donc si vous aimez la cure V
vous serez pas déçu ce qui est cool
c'est que la diagonale 6,73 pouces c'est
très grand c'est un écran 2K 3200 par
1440 pixels et comme on est sur du LTP
on va de 1 à 120 Hertz alors je vous
refais très très rapidement le 1 c'est
lorsque vous êtes sur du always on
display et le 120 Hertz c'est lorsque
vous allez arriver sur des jeux du
gaming qui nécessite d'afficher beaucoup
d'images ça va être également lorsque
vous venez scroller sur des réseaux
sociaux on veut du 120 images par
seconde ça va très très bien vous avez
également un tiroir d'application qui
est cool classé par catégorie donc ça
c'est l'expérience un mi-way que je
trouve très bien fait très bien réussi
alors il y a un truc qui est intéressant
c'est qu'il y a une différence entre la
version mewai que je vais avoir ici sur
mon smartphone français et sur mon
smartphone chinois j'ai une différence
au niveau de miway sur le français j'ai
un mi-way 14 c'est le 14.0.11 sur le
chinois j'ai le 14.0.12 on a la dernière
version un peu au-dessus voilà c'est du
point de détail mais sinon ça fonctionne
bien évidemment basé sur un Android très
ça c'est cool ce que j'aime bien ce que
je trouve pratique c'est que cet écran
une fois de plus pour venir regarder du
contenu il est super agréable très
lumineux à l'extérieur on a un pic à
1900 Nitz je trouve bien calibré il
fonctionne bien l'audio est bon c'est
alors il y a une petite différence au
niveau de l'audio c'est vrai qu'il y a
quelques années chez vous vous avez
sorti un smartphone avec de l'audio qui
a envoyé du bois qui était vraiment
super bien et depuis on retrouve pas
réellement mais aucun smartphone avec
une vraie belle symétrie au niveau des
haut-parleurs en fait là vous avez
haut-parleur la deuxième haut-parleur
qui est là il y a une petite différence
gros truc cool c'est que ça renvoie
vraiment du bousin c'est très très fort
si j'avance un peu il y a de la musique
moins de cheveux blancs et surtout
là-dessus la différence elle est là
c'est plus d'étouffée là mais il y a
vachement vachement sombre alors pour
autant on va pas l'écouter à fond c'est
quand même très très fort on a après
toutes les dernières techno là c'est du
Bluetooth 5.3 vous avez en plus le stade
dragon 8 GN2 ça je vous l'ai dit qu'elle
gros processeur de Qualcom qui est
vraiment très gros focus sur
l'intelligence artificielle je vous en
ai déjà parlé dans une précédente vidéo
à l'extérieur ça c'est très très cool
technologie de RAM c'est de la lpdr 5x
qui ira très vite au niveau du stockage
et de l'UFS 4.0 qui ira très vite en
lecture et en écriture donc là dessus
aussi pas de mauvaise surprise c'est
très très cool ça va très très bien donc
on a les techno qui vont bien autre truc
que j'ai bien aimé c'est que en jouant
des jeux je trouve qu'il y a pas de
chauffe vous voyez souvent on a des
smartphones qui vont venir chauffer les
dernières le standards 8 GN 1 chauffer
quand même là ça chauffe pas des masses
c'est bien alors on sent un petit point
chaud très légèrement là mais très
légèrement et globalement ça va ça vaut
réchauffe pas les mains donc là-dessus
pas de souci vous pouvez faire tourner
beaucoup de jeux il y a toute la
performance qui va bien en fait vous
avez plus de performances que ce dont
vous aurez besoin donc il y a aucun
problème l'autre truc qui est cool c'est
la batterie 4820 il est en période bon
ça va ça va bien à maintenir une journée
mais peut-être deux jours peut-être
aller savoir mais ce qui est cool c'est
que vous avez le bloc de charge inclus
en 120 watts ce qui fait que vous l'avez
rechargé en 20 minutes en 20 minutes le
smartphone vous le recharger à bloc donc
ça c'est cool et ça va très vite alors
après le bloc de charge vous le dise
c'est simple attention il est très gros
c'est un monument en lui-même vous
n'êtes pas obligé de l'avoir tout le
temps avec vous si vous avez un gros sac
qui prend pas trop de place dedans
pourquoi pas pour les prendre bon après
vous êtes pas forcément de recharger en
permanence mais il est là il a inclus ça
c'est plutôt cool également vous avez en
plus de la recherche sans fil si vous
avez besoin que vous voulez recharger
son fil à sa comptoir c'est quand même
très rapide également sacre en toi de
son fils c'est cool dès lors que vous
avez le chargeur 50 étoiles sans fil et
on recharge inversé pour venir charger
soit un autre smartphone soit des
écouteurs on dit what bon et en plus de
ça on a exactement le même score sur un
toutou à quelque chose précise que
j'avais sur la version chinoise ça je
voulais vraiment le vérifier mais c'est
exactement le même truc regardez je vous
les ouvre à côté alors un point de
détail près on est à 1 million 242 669
sur la version chinoise un million 271
333 sur la version française c'est très
rapide et si vous venez regarder après
le détail au niveau CPU au niveau GPU au
niveau de la mémoire tout ça et bien ça
se tient donc on a vraiment la même
chose il y a pas de mauvaise surprise
ici c'est vraiment extrêmement efficace
alors il y a un autre truc qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un
smartphone qui a du wifi 6 ça c'est cool
mais j'ai regardé sur la fiche technique
on me dit qu'il est déjà prêt pour le
wifi 7 ok pourquoi pas sauf que soyons
clairs aujourd'hui il y a rien en wifi 7
donc même si il est prêt on me dit avoir
en tout cas il y a rien en wifi cette
aujourd'hui donc on l'oublie ici donc
wifi 6 ok on a de l'infrarouge donc si
vous voulez utiliser comme une petite
télécommande mais vous avez de quoi
faire alors je vous dis pas de prise
jack ici aussi pas d'extension de
mémoire ici pas extensible c'est soit
256 x 128 dans tous les cas vous avez 12
Go de RAM on a pas la version 8 Go de
RAM c'est que du 12 comme dit Xiaomi
c'est que si c'est 12 + 256 d'ailleurs
je crois même qu'il ne pas on aura pas
en France la version avec 512 donc vous
voyez c'est clair c'est 12 256 non
extensible ici double carte SIM 5G donc
ça c'est plutôt cool également et moi
globalement c'est un smartphone que je
trouve bien le truc qui me laisse un peu
sur ma femme est un peu sur ma faim
c'est qu'ils ont un outil de dingue au
niveau capacité de calcul ils ont une
bête de il y a quelques choix que j'ai
un peu de mal à comprendre du côté de
chez Xiaomi pourquoi une caméra de
selfie qui filme qu'en 1080p alors
derrière vous avez une bête de puissance
pour venir calculer ça sur un capteur 32
megapixels c'est un peu con le choix
aussi de la macro est bizarre même si je
suis pas un très grand fan de Macron
mais bon quitte à avoir des choses
pourquoi pas là je trouve que c'est un
peu pétard mouillé c'est un peu dommage
le capteur de 1 pouce marche très bien
là-dessus il y a pas de mauvaise
surprise donc c'est un très bon
smartphone qui est très bien toute
l'expérience multimédia gaming
visionnage de série visionnage de film
recharge rapide bref tout ça c'est
génial il y a deux trois petits trucs
qui sont légèrement en dessous au niveau
de la photo et de la vidéo mais quand on
a un smartphone et qu'on vient marquer
Leica voyez ici pour moi on peut pas se
permettre ce genre de truc et je trouve
ça un peu con je trouve ça un peu
dommage donc ça reste un très beau
smartphone très bien hyper efficace mais
il a deux trois petits trucs un peu en
dessous surtout qui coûte quand même
attendez la modique somme ça va être ici
je vous le fais comme ça
1299 €, 90 centimes on est à 1300 euros
sur ce smartphone à 10 centimes prêt et
à 1300 euros et bien je m'attendrai
avoir un truc qui soit encore un petit
cran au-dessus il manque deux trois
petits trucs bon voilà il est bien il
peut être encore perfectible mais c'est
un très joli smartphone dans tous les
cas et dans tous les cas Xiaomi a bien
bossé donc à voir ce qui arrivera avec
le Xiaomi 14 pro l'année prochaine on
n'y est pas a priori il y aura pas de
version ultra je ne pense pas il est
déjà bien comme il est là il est quand
même assez cher tout en sachant que il y
a des précommandes je lis tout de suite
donc c'est du 26 février jusqu'au 7 mars
et bien pour l'achat du Xiaomi 13 pro ou
du Xiaomi 13 de Xiaomi 13 c'est 8 bus
256 à 899 € 90 et bien vous avez une
Xiaomi dvp1 e43 pouces qui est offerte
voilà donc vous achetez un smartphone
pas vous avez une TV cadeau pour vous
dire que ça vaut le coup je vous mets un
lien juste en bas dans la description
donc à vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez de ce Xiaomi 13 pro est-ce qu'il
vous plaît ce qu'il vous plaît pas ce
qu'il pourrait vous botter ce que vous
pourriez aller dessus c'est pas souvent
la question quand on va dans le très
haut de gamme dans l'ultra premium
est-ce qu'on préfère aller sur des
marques qui rassurent ça peut être un
Apple c'est encore autre chose parce que
l'OS est différent mais si on va sur
Android c'est très souvent Samsung qui
rassure Xiaomi est derrière en fait
voyons clair aujourd'hui vous avez sur
top 3 sur le podium vous avez Samsung
vous avez Apple vous avez Xiaomi donc
est-ce que vous pourriez aller vous
sécher omis avec un smartphone
extrêmement haut de gamme comme ça ou
est-ce que une note copie ça peut être
un Magic 5 Pro qui va être annoncé très
bientôt qui pourrait vous intéresser
est-ce un pixel 7 Pro de Google est-ce
voilà c'est smartphone dites-le-moi en
bas dans les commentaires et nous on se
retrouve bientôt pour continuer à parler
tech et puis je pense qu'on se fera un
comparatif photo entre d'un côté le
Xiaomi 13 pro et l'autre côté le S23
ultra même processeur on va regarder
comment ils sont vraiment venus
différencier ça au niveau de la photo et
ça ça va être super intéressant mais
c'est pour une prochaine fois donc
pensez à vous abonner je vous embrasse à
bientôt Ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]